члени раптом арні
новий футбольний банери для болю
валянки у клубі wolfsburg ми вас тягу
найбільшого фан-клубу ті та команда
бундесліга
лот аргел мер його президент провини ж
пістолеті іншого в автоконцерні
volkswagen тут у радіусі 10 кілометрів у
сіток чинах шипа в я за нас volkswagen
як би на ця компанія тут не було б
нічого не потрапили в їх зручні суп без
volkswagen і блок із самого клубу
wolfsburg
і критику ви накласти автоконцерну
турік команда пустила інші місяці в
банді слизу
така мої будні на ній чика та пека
volkswagen доводиться за рахунок живота
a-gps років дизельного скандалу турик збут
до авто в дитину перших людей 2
мільярда євро ендом процедур давай
ловці голий раб там називаються хмари все
випадково за на спокій не й пожинають
запитав одесі вояк таке могло 100 тис.
а нас турбу я ситуації нам про volkswagen
golf контексті продаж автомобілів тому
що це наш роботи давати і c100 метушні у
цього місця тут 120 тисяч миша кінців
вольфсбурга пак і половини протягнути
без посередника Volkswagen концерн
фінанси і тут практично всі
наприклад all the штат цілий
туристичний район із музеїв
кінотеатром чи павільйоном з автомобілем
і наука ви йому за і фану було чесне
басейн мішкан цього ліс бурга
за турботу немає їм, що буду з концерном, а
ось же
з їх ним місцям манят стане в нього але
адже за вантажу віра намагається я бренду чи
ясна якщо мінімум я кістки теж по
моєму збоку вигляд побачили на х cepдце був
посмішку важливістю повернувши і не дотягнула
місце де за штати роль випробувано
канал suit in 4 не без гріха або
заслужений clash вона порада хайнц та він
продовжить 10 років до бюджету місця
виглядай подарунки над ходом іванович з не
кішки. 200 мільйонів євро нарік у 2016
враховують на багатому менших над
хеджин вигляд volkswagen теж було до місця
вже скоро ти лави датської на 75 миль
Йоні в євро і можна його
пасти давайте за тих ти ще сильніший she
begins магів але сфінкс вояж по волоссю.
у нас ще є вчать ж не у team стрибати
зі скелі доводи курчати зачатих гаю та
торба сказати ще бург може начебто на
стиль ківав та ми ще чоловік скоро їх
вдома соковиту подивиш минулу
початкового спам volkswagen щось wolfsburg
автоконцерн до місця дикі завжди плече
плечів яку добрий так і в скручуванні годинник